- And what people don't get as well
is I have a couple friends too
it takes them like five hours
to press out their hair, their curls.
Like, my friend Ava, I'm like,
"Are you still in the bathroom?"
- Yes!
- "Like how are you
still in the bathroom?"
and she's like, "Girl, it
takes me forever to get it. "
and I'm like, "Gaw!"
- Girl, that was me at 1:00 a.m.,
pressing my hair.
My momma knows I was
pressing my hair everyday.
Not only the time but the resources.
The wigs that women have to buy
just so that they have the straight hair.
The weaves.
Like we're talking about
a lot of money that puts-
- I do wear weaves.
- I do too.
- several people at a disadvantage.
- But do you always wear naturally now?
- I do. You know it's very rare
when I straighten my hair.
And I think
going through that
experience I told you about,
I think it's just made
me so much more proud
of who I am and it also reminded me
of the position that I'm in
that hopefully I can inspire young girls,
young girls of color,
white girls, brown girls,
every king of girl out there who is
feeling ashamed of some
part of who they are
and what they were given by God.
I don't want them to feel that.
And so I hope that whenever
I rock my curls on the air,
there's one more little girl out there
who's encouraged to do the same.